[Music]
all over the internet there's a photo
here that I don't understand it's been
cropping up all over the place and I
love it
but I don't understand it doesn't look
like you were really with the Obamas you
don't think so but if you had but if you
were you got the three of you smells
something terrible what's going on with
that I mean I remember when I was
wearing that tie I was I was at I think
it was the Dark Knight Rises premiere
right either in New York or London and I
was just I was just making a face at the
fans because you know the paparazzi
photographers are one thing and they can
honestly be a little mean-spirited
sometimes but the fans that come to the
premiere is always really nice sure love
movies and stuff so I like to do
something funny for them so they cropped
it in with the Obama for what I want to
know is it works perfectly why are the
Obamas looking at that made them make
those faces that's what I want to know
buddy actually knows the answer to that
I would love to hear it it's a fence hat
yeah it does look like they're selling
something terrible yeah maybe the 47%
[Laughter]